[Musique]
à l'assemblée il lève la main 1
et bien voilà c'est un petit peu la même
chose sa mode de scrutin dit à la louche
on l'a vu que beaucoup de monde prend
des jumelles et on regarde et on estime
olala par exemple qu'est ce que ça dit
ça dit que abc dick fait lui aussi
voilà j'ai vu que je vérifie pour les
communes de plus de 1000 habitants
le mode de scrutin combine les règles du
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours et
celle du scrutin proportionnel bon dit
comme ça c'est pas très parlant vous
explique les candidats aux élections
municipales se présentent sur des listes
complètes et paritaire paritaire car la
liste compte autant d'hommes que de
femmes placées alternativement sur la
liste est complète car toutes les listes
d'une même commune contiennent le même
nombre de candidats bon ok vous allez me
dire mais concrètement comment ça marche
et bien c'est simple au premier tour 6
liste obtient la majorité absolue
c'est à dire plus de la moitié des voix
elle remporte la moitié des sièges du
conseil municipal les sièges restants
sont alors distribuées
proportionnellement aux scores des
autres listes sauf pour les listes et
obtenu moins de 5 % qui sont éliminés
d'office
cette répartition des sièges et ce qu'on
appelle le mode de scrutin proportionnel
plurinominal ça vous rappelle pas un peu
les chaises musicales tout ça le premier
arrivé prend la place la plus
confortable les autres ça soit sur les
chaînes restantes
et puis le dernier celui qui obtient
moins de 5% et bah il est né d'une idée
bon dans la vraie vie il est rare qu'une
liste obtiennent au moins 51% des voix
dès le premier tour
c'est pourquoi on organise un second
tour tout se passe selon le même schéma
sauf que cette fois on considère que
celui qui obtient le plus de voir
remporté directement la moitié des
sièges
et en cas d'égalité et bien les sièges
sont attribués à la liste dont la
moyenne d'âge est la plus élevée si si
tous les jours sur ce je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel épisode rien
posez vos questions vous aiderez ceux ci
dessous allez ciao